Caption: hi i'm andy dent i'd like to start by
Caption: thanking our sponsors
Caption: i'm here to talk to you about
Caption: lottie and tooling around the lotte
Caption: ecosystem
Caption: lottie is an animation format that as
Caption: you can see from this professional scale
Caption: diagram is a lot smaller than some of
Caption: the ways you may be putting animated
Caption: items on your web pages
Caption: if you attended my talk in 2019 or if
Caption: you want to go back and look it up on
Caption: youtube i talked a lot about disney's
Caption: principles of animation and these first
Caption: few slides
Caption: relate back to that talk as well i still
Caption: break down animation into three reasons
Caption: why so the first one is just to amuse
Caption: yourself or your user
Caption: to give them a little bit of delight in
Caption: the app and the user interface
Caption: sometimes you want to distract people
Caption: how long does it take to load something
Caption: so it's your classic loading spinner
Caption: or when you're getting started if you
Caption: have an app that unfortunately takes a
Caption: long time to get going
Caption: or talking of getting going you may want
Caption: to be informing them about the
Caption: onboarding process or just have a button
Caption: like this hamburger menu here that
Caption: animates to provide a hint as to maybe
Caption: where they should be looking next
Caption: so let's talk about lottie lottie is a
Caption: great open source project it's one of
Caption: those big success stories partly because
Caption: it comes out of companies with deep
Caption: pockets and a real need so it started
Caption: out as a web exporter for adobe after
Caption: effects after effects which some of you
Caption: may be familiar with is the big product
Caption: in motion design
Caption: and somebody wanted to have that out to
Caption: a web player and fortunately for us they
Caption: built an intermediate format using json
Caption: airbnb uses so much on their website
Caption: they wanted to put it inside their
Caption: native apps so they built some really
Caption: cool
Caption: native libraries that are amongst the
Caption: best of breed in how to do graphic
Caption: rendering of vector graphics and release
Caption: those as un
Caption: encumbered open source
Caption: this has become quite an ecosystem so
Caption: i'm going to talk about alternatives to
Caption: adobe's product
Caption: key shape flow and synfig there are also
Caption: other products because this is a simple
Caption: format to export to even the venerable
Caption: 3d blender has got a lotty plugin
Caption: so why does text matter
Caption: text is a great intermediate format
Caption: anybody who's ever been in a complex
Caption: tool chain and had to wrestle with a
Caption: binary format knows you don't want that
Caption: in particular if you are dealing with
Caption: version control text allows your version
Caption: control system to operate really
Caption: efficiently and if you need to chase up
Caption: weird differences in behavior the last
Caption: thing you want to do is be doing a
Caption: visual comparison of two different
Caption: visual rendering side by side when it
Caption: might come down to a few characters
Caption: difference in text files you can diff by
Caption: hand
Caption: and sometimes you just need to tweak the
Caption: color because somebody changed their
Caption: mind about the color blue and you need
Caption: to go through and do a global search and
Caption: replace
Caption: if you have a visual editing tool that
Caption: does styles that's easy if you have one
Caption: which requires you to go and hand edit
Caption: it in 32 different places it's a
Caption: nightmare
Caption: you can see here the little hamburger
Caption: lottie and an idea of what lottie jason
Caption: looks like there's about 100 lines of
Caption: this stuff here for that shape
Caption: lottie files is the dominant site for
Caption: downloads you may be in normal icons
Caption: used to having a plethora of sites where
Caption: you can get the icons and
Caption: be their pngs or svgs in the lotte world
Caption: lottie files is pretty much it and has
Caption: grown into a commercial marketplace
Caption: so let's go over and have a look at
Caption: lottie files
Caption: oops sorry i shall bring up the lottie
Caption: files site that i opened earlier just to
Caption: save it taking a while
Caption: as you can see here lottie allows you to
Caption: search for different hamburgers so if
Caption: you were looking for some design
Caption: inspiration
Caption: on what your hamburger micro
Caption: interactions could look like you can
Caption: find it here even if you're not going to
Caption: use one of these as a starting point
Caption: lottie files also includes a simple
Caption: editor
Caption: so
Caption: we're going to go and play a little bit
Caption: with the lolly that i had
Caption: and play with the melting lolly colors
Caption: as you can see as it's loaded
Caption: even a really simple animation like this
Caption: one
Caption: has got a lot of different components
Caption: let's see what happens when we try and
Caption: change a few colors
Caption: so changing the color of the stick is
Caption: pretty easy
Caption: let's say i want a different flavor of
Caption: lolly i'm gonna go in for something
Caption: that's uh kind of like a a cool one on a
Caption: hot day
Caption: something nice and icy
Caption: oops
Caption: and you can see here why
Caption: you want to maybe go back and do that
Caption: quick search in a place i mentioned
Caption: earlier because now i've got all these
Caption: other
Caption: drips and drip shadows i probably want
Caption: to go and tweak the colors off
Caption: so
Caption: having edited this
Caption: you'll notice there is an export
Caption: available so i can just drop this little
Caption: json file straight down onto my desktop
Caption: or if i'd done a superb job of editing
Caption: it i could put it back on lottie files
Caption: and
Caption: put a description there as to why green
Caption: lollies are much better than pink ones
Caption: so let's go back and look at
Caption: skipping over my pre-saved screenshots
Caption: the graphical editors were really here
Caption: to learn about
Caption: i'm going to talk about three products
Caption: here synfig is
Caption: your classic cross-platform open source
Caption: product so synfig is
Caption: interesting to use a little bit more
Caption: fragile than the others
Caption: most of the keyboard controls will be
Caption: control keys rather than command keys
Caption: for mac users
Caption: it's free so you could go in and hey if
Caption: you notice anything you don't like
Caption: you're always going to fix it and submit
Caption: the source code back up
Caption: it's an older product as well and if
Caption: you've used blender 3d for example it'll
Caption: seem familiar to you it's quite an
Caption: awkward product to use once you get used
Caption: to it however it's amazingly powerful
Caption: i'll talk about that more in a minute
Caption: key shape is a commercial product that
Caption: 47 wants off price so you're seeing
Caption: that's a mac app store download so you
Caption: put it on multiple
Caption: seats for yourself
Caption: and flow is a much higher end product
Caption: that does user interface animation and a
Caption: lot more code generation and export
Caption: features i'll come back to which is why
Caption: it's got that extra price
Caption: all three of these provide the ability
Caption: to draw within the interface but flow
Caption: started more drawing importing from a
Caption: sketch drawing and so their emphasis is
Caption: still more towards tweaking within the
Caption: tool
Caption: so it's and by the way adobe after
Caption: effects is 30 a month unless you've got
Caption: one of those great specials or you're
Caption: doing a high-end bundle
Caption: let's talk about synfig
Caption: so it's more for people who are doing 3d
Caption: movies
Caption: rather than doing little user interface
Caption: animations but it is a visual editor you
Caption: could use to do those animations and
Caption: it's the only one that works on windows
Caption: and linux so it may still be something
Caption: you want to consider but as something
Caption: that's aimed towards people who are
Caption: doing 2d animations you've got the
Caption: ability to animate faces you've got the
Caption: ability to have people walking and doing
Caption: animations of the body
Caption: and it's very much about tweening
Caption: between positions so let's go over to
Caption: synfig and see what that looks like
Caption: so i'm going to start off with a new
Caption: document
Caption: and i just crashed cinfig remember i
Caption: said synfig studio is one of the more
Caption: fragile things this goes with it being a
Caption: um a cross-platform open source product
Caption: so apologies for that minor
Caption: hiccup there let's see if we can launch
Caption: it again
Caption: right we now have a stage on which to
Caption: work
Caption: so i'm going to draw
Caption: a little circle here we'll pretend for
Caption: now this is a bouncing ball
Caption: like older style graphic tools you often
Caption: go in and you use a tool to move things
Caption: and adjust them so all i'm going to be
Caption: doing today is just using the move tool
Caption: but i'm going to make this animated so
Caption: to make it animated i go and turn on
Caption: animation mode with the little green
Caption: person
Caption: and we are now
Caption: in an animation recording mode
Caption: remember i said this is movie oriented
Caption: so it talks about frames
Caption: and
Caption: i'm going to jump to
Caption: one second in the timeline so down the
Caption: bottom here
Caption: all
Caption: animation products have some kind of
Caption: timeline literally how things change
Caption: over time in this case it's move what
Caption: they call the playhead to this this
Caption: position one second 24 frames and at one
Caption: second
Caption: i want the ball to move down to here
Caption: i'm going to jump again to two seconds
Caption: and at that point i want the ball to
Caption: bounce up to there again normally if
Caption: you're going to animate this you would
Caption: squish the ball when it hits but we
Caption: won't worry about that for a simple demo
Caption: like this so i'll jump back out of this
Caption: mode
Caption: very modal stuff because that's your
Caption: classic old style approach and let's go
Caption: back and look what my little animation
Caption: looks like now
Caption: there we go i now have an animated
Caption: moving ball
Caption: i'll save this
Caption: in my animations folder
Caption: and
Caption: animations are exported to lottie from
Caption: synfig using a plugin so i can now do
Caption: that
Caption: and it's created a json plugin for me
Caption: i go over into my animations folder
Caption: i've got
Caption: rec day
Caption: with a little html
Caption: display
Caption: that's synfig
Caption: now let's talk about
Caption: key shape
Caption: key shape is a great vector editor if
Caption: you wanted to do animations from scratch
Caption: even if you're just putting out movies
Caption: or gifs i would recommend this as the
Caption: mac tool to use
Caption: as i said it's only 47 to install on a
Caption: few of your devices
Caption: their import export is via plugins and
Caption: those are all open source so if you want
Caption: to fix their plugins or customize them
Caption: or do your own for a different format
Caption: you can go ahead and do that and as you
Caption: can see from the error message i snipped
Caption: below the melting lolly with just a
Caption: little bit too much melting gooeyness
Caption: for it to cope with
Caption: so i like that little black hamburger i
Caption: had earlier next to the text demo let's
Caption: go over to keyshape
Caption: and
Caption: bring in a hamburger
Caption: because i've already installed the
Caption: lottie plugin the json files show up as
Caption: files i can open and you can see in the
Caption: preview there that really is
Caption: ugly json
Caption: but when it comes in here it is
Caption: beautiful animation
Caption: now because we're not just importing a
Caption: graphic but we're importing a full-blown
Caption: animation we've immediately got a
Caption: timeline down the bottom here
Caption: which
Caption: shows the animation of all of those
Caption: parts and
Caption: i can play it and you'll see it quickly
Caption: animate
Caption: and i can also
Caption: scrub
Caption: the playhead backwards and forwards
Caption: through the timeline to see things
Caption: at my own pace
Caption: this is a commercial product it's been
Caption: around for years and so it does look a
Caption: little bit more friendly and polished
Caption: than
Caption: synfig studio oh the other thing i
Caption: didn't mention synfig studio the
Caption: documentation is a little bit thin
Caption: because it's an open source product
Caption: go ahead and add documentation to it
Caption: people would love that key shape and
Caption: flow have both got superb sites with
Caption: lots of documentation lots of video
Caption: tutorials
Caption: so what i'm going to do to start with
Caption: i'm looking down here i notice we've got
Caption: ketchup here but this is a black
Caption: animation and i loathe the thought of
Caption: black ketchup it brings back horrible
Caption: thoughts of sharehouses and bottles that
Caption: should have been discarded years ago so
Caption: i'm going to change my ketchup to a more
Caption: appropriate ketchup color and i did that
Caption: by selecting the path here that's under
Caption: the ketchup on the left hand side and
Caption: i've now changed that to red but it's
Caption: not showing up
Caption: that's because
Caption: the ketchup has yet to drip so if i
Caption: play with the playhead there goes the
Caption: ketchup and it's now red
Caption: okay
Caption: the person who designed this likes their
Caption: button to pop up at the top i don't
Caption: particularly like the timing of how that
Caption: bun's popping up so let me introduce you
Caption: to the concept of timing curves
Caption: so here we have
Caption: the
Caption: timeline showing how things change
Caption: and sometimes you want them to change at
Caption: a different pace if you look closely on
Caption: the timeline here this top bun has got a
Caption: position changing in a linear mode which
Caption: means it changes evenly but the shape is
Caption: changing with a bezier mode
Caption: what that means is if i go down into
Caption: their bezier edit their timing curve
Caption: editor that bezier is that shape so it's
Caption: actually pretty close to a straight line
Caption: it's changing about the same rate i want
Caption: that to pop up a lot more so i'm going
Caption: to drag these handles if you've ever
Caption: done any spline editing
Caption: in any visual drawing tool this is
Caption: exactly the same as editing curves there
Caption: it's just this is a timing curve
Caption: rather than a
Caption: space curve or a shape curve
Caption: so
Caption: having modified that let's see what
Caption: happens
Caption: now when i play there's a little bit
Caption: more pop as the bun goes up so i'm
Caption: pretty happy with that
Caption: i'm so
Caption: having done all this i'm now going to
Caption: export it
Caption: my export formats because i have the
Caption: plugin include lottie
Caption: and i'm just going to call that my rec
Caption: day
Caption: lottie because i don't want to overwrite
Caption: the one i started with
Caption: i'll put that in my animations folder
Caption: now unlike the other ones
Caption: i don't get a nice
Caption: generated preview html but remember
Caption: lottie files is a very comprehensive
Caption: site
Caption: so let's go back to the logi file site
Caption: and
Caption: amongst oops sorry amongst the lottie
Caption: files
Caption: tools at the top here
Caption: in the design area is a previewer this
Caption: allows you to take any json file you've
Caption: found somewhere else or you've created
Caption: with one of these other tools
Caption: and preview it on the web
Caption: so here's my
Caption: hamburger rec day that we just edited
Caption: and when i open it on the lottie file
Caption: site
Caption: ta-da we have a poppy bun and red
Caption: ketchup so lottie files loves you to
Caption: share and i could go in and share right
Caption: away i think we've done enough with that
Caption: for now
Caption: so
Caption: let's go back to our presentation and
Caption: we'll skip through a couple of carefully
Caption: saved screens and talk about flow
Caption: as i said earlier flow is focused on
Caption: user interface animation
Caption: so whilst it includes lottie export for
Caption: the web it's also got native code
Caption: wrappers for lottie so it'll export a
Caption: workable ielts or android project you
Caption: can show your lottie within and
Caption: very quickly mention a non-lottie topic
Caption: one of the reasons it's so expensive is
Caption: it does these compilable native
Caption: animations so if you had
Caption: 20 buttons that were animated apart from
Caption: driving your users crazy that screen
Caption: would probably have something like about
Caption: 160k worth of assets if they were lottie
Caption: files if they were generated as
Caption: native compiled stuff that would come
Caption: down to maybe
Caption: 2k of binary change
Caption: so
Caption: flow
Caption: originally started importing from sketch
Caption: and the important thing to know about
Caption: this this is a tweening thing where it
Caption: is mapping
Caption: the starting
Caption: artboard and an artboard in sketch is
Caption: just a container for a bit of a drawing
Caption: to the ending artboard and they have to
Caption: be utterly identical so structurally
Caption: they have to be the same i've just hand
Caption: edited a bit of the ddd logo here
Caption: and you can see i want to end up with
Caption: some eyes on there if you look down here
Caption: you can see i've actually also got those
Caption: eyes
Caption: on the starting position so my structure
Caption: is identical
Caption: however
Caption: the opacity is turned down to zero
Caption: so let's
Caption: whizz over into flow
Caption: and create a new document
Caption: and i'm going to link a sketch file it
Caption: could be starting from figma which is in
Caption: beta or it could be starting from
Caption: an svg
Caption: so when you open the sketch file it'll
Caption: go through and it'll do previews of all
Caption: the artboards in there i've only got the
Caption: two in here so i'm just obviously going
Caption: to drag the one i called start and the
Caption: one i called end that's just my
Caption: convention doesn't mean anything
Caption: and that's it i now have an animation so
Caption: it's immediately it's worked out it
Caption: should interpolate between those two if
Caption: i play that
Caption: i've got those two shapes moving and the
Caption: eyes appearing which is the opacity
Caption: being animated
Caption: down the bottom we have what's possibly
Caption: now becoming familiar as a timeline and
Caption: they actually call it a timeline which
Caption: makes it really obvious to you
Caption: and you can see
Caption: the attributes it's worked out that's
Caption: animating between there
Caption: so
Caption: i don't know if there was actually any
Caption: change in the x position obviously the y
Caption: position things moved up and the opacity
Caption: changed
Caption: so let's say
Caption: i wanted the green to be a little bit
Caption: cheeky and to start winking at us a
Caption: little bit earlier
Caption: so the winking effect is basically just
Caption: the opacity when does the eye show up
Caption: i'm going to
Caption: scale my timeline so it's easy to edit
Caption: and i'm going to make that
Caption: eye open
Caption: an awful lot
Caption: earlier now let's see what happens
Caption: there we go in fact that that's a little
Caption: bit too quick so why don't i go and slow
Caption: down my timeline so i'll make it four
Caption: seconds long
Caption: and i'll scale it if i just wanted to
Caption: add extra animations at the end i'd say
Caption: expand but i want it stretched over that
Caption: time so now i have a four second
Caption: animation i'll go back to beginning
Caption: and that eye winks pretty quickly
Caption: let's go and play with some curves
Caption: so
Caption: i want
Caption: my pink
Caption: to move up quickly
Caption: i don't want the eyes to vanish
Caption: out of the
Caption: shape so i'm actually going to have to
Caption: go in
Caption: i'm going to expand this a little bit
Caption: and you can see here i've got
Caption: my
Caption: timing curve for opacity so for y
Caption: position for the pink right eye the pink
Caption: left eye
Caption: and the overall d
Caption: i'm going to change those what am i
Caption: going to do with those let's see
Caption: how about
Caption: we're a bit slow to start
Caption: so i've got all three selected
Caption: and i can just drag those oops i haven't
Caption: got all three selected because i missed
Caption: them
Caption: drag that
Caption: click on that one so now i've got all
Caption: three i'm holding down the command key
Caption: to get a multiple selection much as you
Caption: would with shapes
Caption: and so if i drag those three over what
Caption: happens
Caption: so we're taking a one second
Caption: start
Caption: and it slowly comes up and matches the
Caption: others
Caption: but i want to have a bit of a sense of
Caption: panic in there having been left behind
Caption: so
Caption: pink is going to
Caption: come up with a different easing curve
Caption: so i've got the three things selected
Caption: one two three and over on the right hand
Caption: side here you can see i can choose
Caption: easing so this
Caption: has got three keyframes selected that
Caption: are all compatible properties
Caption: and let's just make it
Caption: something that
Caption: a little bit slow and then
Caption: jumps up pretty quickly because we
Caption: started late let's see what happens now
Caption: whoops yep and everyone else is catching
Caption: up
Caption: let's
Caption: zoom that
Caption: down a bit so you can see that again
Caption: voila
Caption: if i want to export that from flow
Caption: file export and i say i'm exporting to
Caption: code
Caption: and i can now choose
Caption: a lotty
Caption: web format
Caption: i've got to choose my timeline
Caption: and if i open that
Caption: you see we have a nice preview again
Caption: in which we can see our animation
Caption: okay and
Caption: with that
Caption: finish flow
Caption: so we've discussed three tools you can
Caption: do with
Caption: visual editing remember
Caption: key shape allowed me to bring in the
Caption: lottie document and visually edit it the
Caption: other two could only export to lottie
Caption: and are there any questions about lottie
Caption: or animation general
Caption: thank you